So over the long weekend, Donald Trump pulled a
stunt where I guess to prove how healthy he is
and how wonderfully everything is going with his
corona virus case in advance of restarting rallies
and town halls and maybe debates, which he did
already. He staged a so-called medical exam on
FOX. He has now it really was not actually an
exam. It was a conversation with that same FOX
News Dr. Marc Siegel, who a couple of months ago
did an interview with Trump about his cognitive
state and said Trump was amazing. His cognitive
state is just stunning. This medical exam, which
wasn't a medical exam, is hilarious because if you
listen to Donald Trump, he doesn't answer a single
question. We learn nothing during this entire
interview other than by process of elimination,
that at the time of this interview, Donald
Trump was still positive for a corona virus.
That's all we learned during this fake medical
exam. So let's get into it. Trump is asked about
symptoms and basically says nothing other than
he didn't feel strong and insists he had no
breathing issues, problems that you had last
Friday, like when you went into Walter Reed.
What was the two most prominent
symptoms that you had?
I think I didn't feel strong. Didn't feel really
strong. I didn't have a problem with breathing,
which a lot of people seem to have.
I had none of that.
But I didn't feel very strong. I didn't
feel very vital. I didn't feel like the
president of the US should feel. And I
knew there was something a little bit off.
And the doctors at Walter Reed were incredible.
We've known for a week, though, that Trump was
given oxygen at least once and probably multiple
times. And there were numerous reports about
trouble breathing. But again, asked what were your
symptoms? A seemingly straightforward question.
Trump doesn't name any, but you'll see
in the next question that all of a sudden
symptoms start to crop up. Next question is, were
you scared? And Trump lists medications he got.
Were you scared? Were you frightened?
Well, I took the Regeneron
and Eli Lilly makes a similar very similar
medicine, but you have Regeneron, you have the Eli
Lilly version of it, and it just within a period
of 24 hours, I felt very different. I think
I could have left the hospital a lot earlier,
but it made a tremendous difference, Mark. And,
you know, markedly so. And I just felt very
good. It. You would have sort of a sore throat
just to add to to what we were saying. But but I
felt really very, very good after taking this for
a period of time. It's a transfusion, not a shot.
Reports actually are that Trump was panicking as
his symptoms started and started asking people
at the White House if he was going to die
like his friend who died of Corona virus, but
noticed that Trump then adds a symptom there.
I guess he forgot before. He says, well, you
know, I did have a sore throat when he was
asked about symptoms. He said I didn't really have
anything other than I didn't feel super strong.
So, OK, we've added a symptom. Trump is then
asked about medications. And this is so funny.
I think Trump just doesn't understand anything.
I think he's just not a particularly bright guy.
He says he's not taking any medications right
now, but mentions that like eight hours ago he
did take medications. Take a look at this thing.
And right now, I'm medication free. I'm not taking
any medications as of, you know, probably eight
hours ago or so, IV medication free, which frankly
makes me feel good. I don't like medication.
So Trump seems confused about his own medication
regimen. He says, well, as of eat out in the
last eight hours, I've taken nothing. Well,
have you finished courses of those medications?
Because if you take something daily, there is a
point in the day where you could say, listen, it's
been 23 hours since I took anything. Well, but
are you off the medications or have you just not
taken your next dose yet? Bizarre way of answering
every single question. Trump later asked again
about medications and now he sounds completely
different. He says, I think really I'm not taking
anything. And we are pretty much finished with
medications, which is not the same as I am
no longer on anything. Take a look at this.
What are you taking right now as of today?
I think really nothing. We pretty much finished
and now we'll see how things
go, but pretty much nothing.
We had our final doses of just about everything,
actually, that the original transfusion that's
supposed to last for about four months.
So Trump is pretty much taking no medication
and basically had his last doses just a few
hours earlier. Like, does he even understand
his own treatment? I had a conversation with some
friends over the weekend where we were talking
about it. We talked specifically about this
interview, which we had all seen and we were kind
of arguing about is Trump here being strategically
vague on purpose? When he answers these questions
or does he not really understand what's going on
and whether he's taking medications or like his
own treatment? And the consensus was it could
be a little bit of this, a little bit of that.
Then Donald Trump is asked about,
well, what medical tests did you have?
Did you have a CAT scan? Trump doesn't
seem to know what he had. Take a look.
You would feel comfortable. Can you
tell me a little bit about the tests
you had in the hospital? Do you have
a CAT scan? And what did that show?
Yeah, they tested the Loving's. They
have a credible equipment at Walter Reed.
In fact, they said, no, you could leave your
jacket on. And that's the first that's ever
happened. Leave your shirt on. Leave your jacket
on. I said I'll take it off anyway if you want.
But literally, they tested the lungs. They
check for the lungs and they tested it with
different machinery. They have incredible
stuff that I've never even seen before.
And it tested it tested good initially. I
think they had some congestion in there,
but it tested ultimately it
tested good. And with each day,
it got better. And I think that's why they
wanted me to say frankly. But the CAT scans
were amazing. The equipment was incredible.
I've never seen equipment like this before.
The CAT scans were amazing. Imagine that.
And of course, tests like no one's ever
seen before. I like that. He says they checked
for the lungs. They did find the lungs there,
reportedly, according to the scans they did. They
did find Trump's lungs. And medical experts are
unanimous. Trump. The lungs were there as far
as Trump is concerned. But it all tested good.
Congestion in the lungs, maybe. Who knows?
It's not clear whether Trump actually means
what the medical term lung congestion means or
whether Trump means he was stuffed up in his nose,
which, of course, would be another another
symptom he had not explained recently.
It's all wacky. And then the big. And, of
course, that many of us were waiting for.
Have you been tested and are you
negative? The answer is a pretzel.
It's a verbal inkblot. Take a look at this.
Are you tested? I heard you. I heard you
said you were going to test again
today. Have you been retested?
I have been retested and I haven't even found out
numbers or anything yet. But I've been retested
and I know I'm at either the
bottom of the scale or free.
When is your next test going to be?
I don't know. Probably tomorrow,
Mark. They test every couple of days, I guess.
But it's really at a level now that's been
great. Great to see it disappear.
So I haven't gotten the numbers,
but I'm at the bottom of the scale or free. And
he's at a great level when it comes to the virus.
Are you positive or negative for corona virus?
Obviously, if he was negative at the time,
he would have said it. If you look at the letter
put out by his doctor just a few hours later,
you will noticeably see that Trump tested negative
is missing from the letter. The letter says Trump
meets criteria to stop isolation. He's no longer
a transmission risk. He's been fever free for
more than 24 hours. There is no longer evidence of
actively replicating virus. Trump has decreasing
viral loads. No mention of Trump tested, negative
recovered. And you can bet your ass that if
he tested negative, they would be saying it.
Ultimately, we learned or were told that Trump
tested negative, literally en route on a plane to
a mass rally in Florida last night, which we will
talk about a little later. But as you can see,
Trump cleared by his doctor to return to public
events and campaigning. And indeed, he did. And we
will get to that later. Make sure you're following
me on Twitter. I'm Deepak Pacman on Twitter.
What do you make of this bizarre
suppose it medical exam, which was a doctor at
asking Trump questions that he didn't even answer.
Let me know what you make of it on
Twitter. We'll be back after this.